good morning Millennials it doesn't feel
like a good morning honestly after we I
just put so much energy into saying that
I need a few to wake up with puffy eyes
makes it hard to do your makeup it looks
here on your eyelids and then you're in
a bad mood I did the weirdest thing this
morning that's so funny that you said
that for the past maybe months there has
been an eyelash on my left eye that's it
that's wrong no Tom it's not a road
I used that serum and I really feel like
I just lather it all over that like I
had an eyelash grow like on my eyelid
like yeah it's not on my lash line it
was like an inch up and it was every
time I wear my lashes and like start to
do my mascara like this one
[ __ ] eyelash would just like go rogue
and today I taste it
it's teenagers hurt I thought it was
really gonna hurt I didn't feel it at
all I pulled it and I think I didn't get
it and then I went to there was there it
is your serum work yes oh my god
snitch how would you be thinking that
cuz you said it so weird how would you
pronounce the word s er um serum serum
and is it does have spirit serum s beer
with a lot of lyrics serum no serum has
spirit with a lot of lyrics zero is like
the word where you actually say it like
that right but spirit no it's spirit and
lyrics it's lyrics not lyrics but if her
snitch it's whatever she wants it to be
and she's getting her ears parsed later
today I would like to really give a
major shout out of appreciation to the
toasters because not one person has
mentioned the three shirts have been
wearing on rotation probably for the
last month of shows but because I'm
moving like I really had just given up
on my apartment like my [ __ ] is ever
like I can't wait to meet our new
apartment just to find all the clothes
that I purchased in the past two years
right look because if you actually shop
a lot yes I know you say that you don't
have clothes and then you wear the same
three shirts but like you're getting
incoming packages you're always talking
about your ASOS ordering them but then
you never show us because I could get an
ace to start with like a bluff said I
love I wear it I clean it and then once
it comes back for the laundry who knows
where to go yeah but in my new apartment
I have a major huge walk-in closets what
I will be able to see all my clothes to
see your clothing is an amazing thing I
don't see my clothing I see my clothing
now but for two years I literally lived
out of a sleepover bag because yeah
like pack my bag every night let's go
and my friend's house to go to Zacks and
so like I pick my clothes out every
night I was always between places it was
so hard but now that I have like a
closet where I can see everything I hope
it's paying off
yeah like I hope you guys are realizing
a difference and like just to have all
my bags be in one place where like your
should be taking care of you and my
closet has shoe washed shoe wall like
I'm so excited so until then I like my
life doesn't start till octa November
4th October 1st my name is Bailey it's
been a year oh my god he has to do
something for the one of course of
course
maybe Mon or like have the real well or
doesn't matter or it doesn't matter
because we're like Wyatt Earp and you
know we're not back with me where I'm
had a major media company behind us we
couldn't do things like that but now we
can totally that's crazy said to me your
time really flies speaking of time
flying this is our last show here till
Wednesday because tomorrow holiday
weekend the final summer fridays upon us
and you know we're not gonna sit on
travel Brad's wells less good summer you
know we're not gonna squander that
opportunity my name is labor day so I
hope you guys are enjoying not living
Tuesday or moving whoa yeah yeah hey
whoa I would do a speech on the two
situation except she has her first day
of class so I'm taking that as a sign
for me to take the day off too you know
what I thought about yesterday that I
would love to get some advice from my
fellow toast her dog moms it's probably
really confusing for Theo cause like to
move he's gonna like leave like he just
always leaves an apartment and like
never come back to the place where he
grew up you don't mean I do and I feel
like at first maybe helping commutes but
I feel like Theo is just gonna adapt
like he's an adapter Tyco sort of dog I
couldn't agree more but and my manager
sathi is like you have to like take the
outlet to Jackies and then bring him
back when all the boxes are unpacked
because it can be very alarming but if
you like his dog is just psychotic like
feels normal and fine and he'll adjust
and also Theo like goes with the flow
like he was a lot of things he's
definitely beautiful he's definitely not
very smart
that sure definitely goes with the flow
he's a team player and I don't think
he'll hold you up I think he's gonna be
excited for mom and dad that they're
moving on up in the world and I think he
really believes like home is where the
crate is home is where the crate is and
like
I feel like he's ready to move on up in
the world like you guys are going like
swanky style and I feel like Theo is
ready for a little more fabulousness in
his life I look a little scared because
my building it's like a really adult
like I'm me and that are definitely the
youngest people maybe by like 20 or 30
years you're worrying about the behavior
no I'm just no no it's a dog-friendly
building there's tons of dogs and I got
a full-time dog walker I'm no longer
using Wagon why because it's like a like
a fancy building and if like every day
it's like a new person they're gonna be
like Wyatt right and now that I started
thinking about like finding a dog walker
I realized how expensive wag is and it's
really good for like when you're in a
bind but to rely on it like when you're
working is not smart because now that
I'm like thinking of how many wags I've
done in the past year it's like oh my
god
it's he it's literally like uber yes so
it's like I'm supplying to people's
full-time movers is he gonna be walking
with other dogs I don't even have walk
friends well you know people are really
like against that and I'm not because I
think it's great life for socialization
but it is harder to focus and like in
New York when there's cars everywhere
it's obably better just to have one dog
per person but I'm gonna be bad if he
was walking like with one other dog he
loves dogs I feel like it depends on the
dog walker like sometimes they like put
them on one leash and it's like anarchy
yeah
Walker like has like a good system and
is keeping an eye and I think like three
dogs could yeah it could be nice I'm
just excited because now we're moving
way closer to a park and I just think
Theo will just thrive he'll thrive he's
such a park boy yeah he'll definitely
lose weight yeah I'm excited for him he
really needs a haircut but like you
don't understand I can't do anything
until I move like I I can't be bothered
with anything well luckily for you and
for us you are moving in four days like
Mario he was at my house it's gross
mm-hmm I've started hearing yeah and
it's kind of nice no because you used to
be super crazy yes but now it's just
boxes everywhere
it's boxes and it's like the laundry I'm
not putting it away like we're packing
it in two days honey you never put away
your laundry like I just I can't be
bothered with just all this crap and
this new apartment comes with a storage
unit so like all my suitcases that like
I have no place or storage I'm just I'm
going to be a queen I'm excited for you
me too
anyways are we ready to jump and this
seems so abrupt yesterday we took 40
minutes before we started talking about
the store anything else but yesterday
was the first time I really watched our
show I never watch our show you watch
yesterday's episode yeah because it's
like there's nothing I can do
it's happened and like I just gave
myself it's like over analyzing things
that I said I'm like was out of hand
said you know like I really I give
myself a pitch so I just think it's
better to wash my hands of the whole
situation but I saw a little clip and I
like thought I look so skinny yesterday
so I just watched like 20 minutes and I
was like damn we're good we are good
good like poppin the doses mitosis pipe
in high AR oh my god I mean March 2.0 is
definitely coming and it's a more
elevated design merch and like more
elevated as a time like people are
giving their ideas in there so funny
like a lot of major that says the
business woman's special done or a
briefcase a briefcase that says the
McKenzie Kyle o rare right but those
need to be limited edition because how
many of you would actually find out if I
mean I would use it just because like
that's epic but like it would need to
have a strap yeah I would use it a
cool-looking briefcase there's not
cool-looking briefcases for women okay
really because of bad I'm in the market
Ben was like all about how he doesn't
have a briefcase and been like refuses
to wear a backpack which I love him
because I hate when I told men wear
backpacks like North Face backpacks I
hate it like I just hate it I have a
side bag a backpack is not I'm not going
my man wears a backpack like he wears a
nice to me backpack so it's the lesser
of all email evils but it's still a
backpack and you know what Ben you got
him a gorgeous but I was gonna say I got
Ben like literally for Hanukkah like I
really like invested it was like a
hunter emerald green this like a
beautiful leather Louie bits ha Louie
look tall even though a Vuitton makes it
takes me a Margo bunch of first episodes
of Real Housewives of New York laughs on
your story oh my god what do you think
snitch it was good I don't really think
it's what the show is like now that of
course is so different but honestly it's
like I don't know how we stuck with it
because it was such a bad show back then
like the ladies weren't even friends no
but like this was so new this whole
concept was so new that we were just
like so happy to be along for the ride
have a peek into the countess's home
when her children have lice well like
that is shocking now the bar is so high
because they keep having to one-up but
the most shocking thing is I don't think
we really realize Luann's fall from
grace and the way that people like
regard Sonia is like having this life
and then like now she's like the
spinster
that's LuAnn I totally forgot first of
all the wins townhouse I know
Luann's house in the Hamptons I know she
was at a ceremony getting an award like
I really forgot erican heart associate
with like with the count and she's like
playing golf and like Jill goes to see
her and she's like hugging her husband
and I was just like oh my god like the
way people feel about Sonja is now the
way I feel about LuAnn well and then
last night on the reunion they sort of
touched on that that like all of this
whole like fall from grace that she's
had isn't because of the Tom thing it's
because like of the life that she lost
and like she just wants that love and
that life back I know and they spent a
lot of time talking about her when she
wasn't there and I found that really
boring I just have an annoying because
it's like oh I only wanted to hear from
Bethenny because she obviously knows the
tea
Dorinda Giovanni like it's just she
talks about how she loves who in and
then says the nastiest things of all
time about her and then says I can't
wait to get back to where we were even
though I'm saying things that I can't
get back right now also but we're gonna
recap it later but like Carole pulling
out that list of like fake insults
saying she wouldn't say that to her
worst and I mean like those weren't even
you know like she's Carole started at
the top of the show with some like you
know she came in with some points
Bethenny came in with some points by the
end of the show she was saying just
complete nonsense she said I didn't talk
bad about you I'm not once not like
that's a full-blown like doesn't he
never said I didn't talk bad about you
she just said you talk bad about me and
that's not bullying but I totally and
wait wait Chucky's like how do you not
watch the show Oh Carole saying that
like you know she tried the whole season
to get back to normal but Bethenny
wasn't interested like that's just
exactly the opposite of what happened
it's all we saw was like Bethenny making
a constant effort like texting go in a
lunch having conversation and Carole was
just like back when she's like this is
too much this is too much which by the
by she's entitled to feel like it's too
much but don't lie and say that you were
trying to get back together and Bethenny
wasn't because it's literally the exact
opposite it was so strange and I feel
like towards the end we got some justice
but it's like Carole got too much time
to run her mouth and spew lies and it's
like Jackie weren't paying close
attention this season you might think
she was right but like she's not just
because of the volume of like her and
Dorinda yelling also think if I watch
Real Housewives the way I watched back
to her in paradise with like one ear
open I might believe Carole cuz I don't
know I didn't pay attention to
everything but housewives audience are
extremely invested and they have
overwhelmingly taken Bethenny side and
we knew that Carole said oh shut the
[ __ ] up Andy are you so full of [ __ ]
Andy but I didn't know that she said oh
are you scared of her too and like it
was it was in that moment
any question you had about why Cara
wasn't coming back next was answer was
answered so I'm excited for that I'm
gonna send us a recap but let's keep
going okay are you ready for the fast
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast okay honestly this
week you guys Hollywood celebrity it on
must be more interesting I've been
pulling teeth this week but you know
what I'm also of the mind that no news
is good news
of course I mean everyone is on vacation
you know the last week in August it's
like when all the rich people go to San
Tropez Burning Man Burning Man
yes so like I guess well well we'll get
back to our regular scheduled program
maybe next week hopefully after like a
five-day break something interesting
happen one thing except of course the
minute we got this show like yeah Nick a
brown girl pregnant Kourtney's pregnant
did you see the video some Nick and
Priyanka's families dancing at the
engagement party like it is so real
what like the moms that you want Jonas
mom tweeted thank you for being so she
tweeted a video of her and Priyanka's
mom dancing saying thank you for being
so patient with me
and my bad dance moves I miss you
hashtag engagement party but like you
know that it's like 26 year old
publicist we're at that you know DUI I
don't know I don't know what to believe
anymore all I know is that they will
stop at nothing to make us think it's
true and now they're bringing their moms
into it which is just not cool honestly
yeah maybe I hope they all are getting
along you know at least have a good time
with the live course they got a trip to
India that's pretty cool yeah and she's
now been considered to be in Marvel
something or other sorry everyone's
careers everyone living success all
around America scenic Jonases star like
rising from this what's happening to him
he just put out a song I haven't even
read snitch the one with like when DJ
yeah I listened to it it I didn't like
it I just never liked everything
I just don't think his music is very
good me neither it went from Olivia
culpo jealous to like him I don't even
think he was destined to be a solo
artist like I think he was him and Joe
and Kevin were all like mediocre at
specific things and them together were
fantastic not one of them is really
supremely talented at one certain thing
well Joe got that memo because he
started a band right and by the way
they're so successful and they have like
so many hits and like that was a perfect
transition out of the Jonas Brothers
Kevin like now we're just realizing like
it maybe it wasn't
his thing and like being a family man
and a business man and living in New
Jersey perfect I don't think that Nick
Jonas was meant to be this like
heartthrob solo singer he's just not
that good
well then maybe that explains why he's
out here thirsting with Priyanka yeah
needs to like up his career he needs to
start a rise maybe that's possible okay
well our first story is that Kanye could
be the only Kardashian who still likes
Caitlyn Jenner Kanye West hasn't
completely excommunicated Caitlyn Jenner
unlike the majority of the Kardashian
family the rapper desiigner sent Jenner
and her rumored 22 year-old girlfriend
Sophia Hutchins clothes from his new
easy collection and shared Jenner's
response on Twitter so Caitlyn texted
Kanye a photo of Sophia wearing Wow
where is he it's so people wearing the
easy outfit saying Sophia love the first
set of looks your team left and went all
easy for her travel outfit today
we love your looks thanks again I really
think I need your welcome so well wrong
grammar I really fall like in the middle
of a lot of this Kardashian drama like
when it comes to Kourtney versus the
world like I'm firmly on the team of the
world but with Caitlyn like I don't know
a part of me like feels for her and I
don't know I just I don't know where to
land here and I love that Kanye like
doesn't listen to the Kardashians like
they all decided to hate Caitlin and
they're so loyal to one another that
they hate Caitlin like Kanye does
whatever he wants in he can and I like
that I like that too and I'm glad that
like Caitlin's not totally like thinking
about Caitlin's life like makes me sad
sometimes so I'm glad that she has like
a little piece of family Plus Caitlin
still does have like Brody and Brandon
and Leah and like yeah Bert Bert yeah
Bert and I think there's one more girl
but I see yes from the first marriage
and from the first marriage yeah she's
like so low-key I know I just feel like
he really had this amazing life Bruce
and the one thing that was wrong with it
was like who like living a lie and it
took so it took 60 years for him to like
untell that lie and once he did like
things just went downhill
yeah I good to lose your family in order
to truly be yourself and yes he's
totally guilty sorry she's totally
guilty for all the things she said about
Kris and like she didn't help her
circumstance but at the same time like I
just can't help but like feel sad for
her sometimes me too me too
and it must have been like hard to go
from all the attention in the world
then all of a sudden like literally
nobody cares about Diane Sawyer the book
the TV show the tour - nothing right I
wonder what her financial situation is
I'm just curious I think she I think she
does fine also I don't think she has
actually now she probably has a lot of
expenses like Bruce didn't have a lot of
expenses right but glam is expense and
also she loves like fast cars and
helicopters oh right gossip let's
explore that's an expensive hot member
when Kris used to make first like keep
his like two helicopters in the garage
and he would have like no room in the
house yeah like the mansion that's
hilarious that is hilarious
honestly like the good old days of like
so what we're on season what of
Kardashians 15 13 10 years season 13 I
really like think that I just said that
was such a certainty like I know the
peak Kardashian time was like season 7
15 seasons why it was seasons that I
don't know but like the time when Kim
was living in that house that I adore
pre Chris Humphries our post Kris
Humphries pre host post I said I don't
know I don't know but I don't think of
it like that I think of it like Rob was
just starting to get fat and they were
like he was still like normal but like
they would she caught robbing her
kitchen like eating Chinese food and
getting a burger that was post Chris and
I think that was during Kanye because
that was when Rob missed the wedding
because he felt that he wasn't like
totally Kim and Kanye where was she
living in that house still I think so I
never had a home together aren't hearing
and they still like Don the Bel Air
house the sunken plays they keep moving
they you sold it to that russian pop
star who's on the show because it's part
of her real estate deal it's so weird
no for me the golden days I don't know
like there where there are a few like
first of all when the three girls were
like what they saw was the height of
their career like doing Sears came like
pursues Kris because she thinks that's
the best thing she curls to Mir but then
after Kris Humphries like you they lost
me hardcore hardcore he was such a nice
boy he was such a nice boy and like just
because of the NBA lockout and that's
why I have a gripe with the NBA because
grace yeah is that word I think great
all right great and that sounds right I
right with the MBA because if it wasn't
for the lockout Kris Humphries would
have been working he wouldn't have been
all the home all the time like being
annoying and unemployed and they could
have made it work also why were they
living in a small apartment with
Kourtney and Scott I do not know when
they're at the top of the world yeah
like those spin-offs where they went to
like it was so forced like when they
went to Miami Kourtney and khloé like
that was funny they had a - or like it
really made sense when Kourtney and
Khloe went to the Hamptons that was the
work that was Khloe did not want to be
there Kourtney's like boring and wanted
to live on a lake and like do yoga and
like that was really for her and Khloe
was out there even though she was just
starting a relationship with French
Montana and she was like in such a bad
place with the Lamar stuff and she went
as a good sister I'm like that was the
worst spin off I think ever ever and not
only were they not like it made no sense
they weren't in the right place to do it
but it's also like the Hamptons are
pretty boring unless you're like going
out all the time which they don't so
it's like a rebuttal the inner house and
buy your pool and that's it yeah and
it's like there are there is like a very
small like party scene in the Hamptons
but it's like private they're not gonna
[ __ ] film it right and I don't think
they were hitting that up this was like
before everyone started drinking yeah
except I think French and Khloe used to
party
yeah me too that's why they dated all
right Khloe you always forget she's the
youngest of those three right so like I
mean five years ago like she was you
know yeah so I don't blame her but it's
you just think of them as like old
married ladies now yeah but Khloe was a
party girl so crazy it's crazy how like
the Jenna's like every time you think
they're at their height and then it's
only like you know all good things must
come to man like it hasn't ended yet no
it's a Kris Jenner
conglomerate with okay interesante okay
switching gears a little bit
Meghan MacRay Meghan McCain Christ
during John McCain's Arizona service
family and friends continue to mourn the
death of John McCain after his brave
battle with cancer on Wednesday morning
the body of the late Senator arrived at
the Arizona State Capitol building
soon after select guests were able to
walk up to the flag draped casket and
pay their respects Cindy McCain patted
the casket and then leaned over and
kissed it the couple's children
including a visibly upset Megan McCain
followed close behind when Meghan had a
moment to visit she was seen weeping
before continuing with the memorial that
landed on what would have been John's
82nd birthday
that's so weird yeah the view co-host
was escorted by her husband Ben and
stayed close to her brother Jimmy McCain
during the service her husband is like
so uh no they're so huge we like I like
have this special place in my heart for
Megan McCain like I just love her cuz
like I love the cheese like Bravo and
when she first came on the view what I
follow the view on Twitter I don't know
why because I just think they do like
interesting topics sometimes like when
it's not about like politics and it's
like about The Bachelor and they have
this like really like interesting like
feminist view on The Bachelor but she
liked it I was obsessed with her dad but
you never saw someone like just talk
about their dads so frequently yeah and
like what's so interesting is that in
the toasters group which I can get very
political sometimes someone posted like
no politics just like really sad that
John McCain died in like literally every
single comment was like from everyone
was just like yes so much respect that's
so nice I know and like I just like
loved Megan McCain and like I think it's
so weird when they take pictures of
people at funerals like when nature
pictures of Bethany at tennis shields
funeral I think that was like the worst
thing the world and it's just the
perfect example of how disgusting the
world is like not even a funeral is
sacred
oh really a private citizen he's not
faint like he's not well-known and it
makes sense because John McCain is like
a civil servant and like that's just the
world that we live in but like it's just
really sad that those pictures exist and
the pictures which I think we are
running are just so sad so sad the whole
thing is really sad and I just I hope
they find peace me too and I'm happy
that it happened while the view is off
oh is it yeah they take a hiatus I think
they're back in September so like she'll
have some time oh that's so nice yeah I
thought she was just missing work no you
can't miss the view why they always have
subs yeah the view is like by the way
there was like two people now leading
the view who I don't know I don't know
drama you know I kind of do I know
because Meghan McCain is like bringing
the view into the 21st century like
having Andy Cohen and LuAnn on but I
know there's joy who is like the
scariest woman alive I hope I never ever
meet her
Whoopi who just seems like the best and
like so open-minded Meghan and then
there's two girls a blonde girl and a
brunette girl who I don't know when I
believe that they're both leaving and
who's coming in oh well there are rumors
I don't think it's come out yet there
are rumors that it's on and Navarro and
I don't know who that is but it's just
so funny because she's the same exact
name as my manager
that's assistant like it spelled the
same way and do and it's like when when
I got hurt you know I like I don't know
I was on Google I'm like she it's a
political activist so now I just like
laugh about it I don't know if it's true
but she's rumored to be on Sarah Haines
is leaving it's much that's a lie girl
yeah okay and I think maybe someone else
maybe not they said just one is leaving
and I don't know what side of the aisle
Sarah Haines is yeah but they try and
fill it like with what she was they need
to do a view of like such strong
personalities with such a differing
polar opposite opinions polarizing but
like about Bravo shows like totally
staunch Bethenny people and staunch car
and then staunch Cortney people and
staunch like everyone else normal and
like stylish leo people yeah and staunch
like just parrot that's open also but
the people who like really feel so
strongly about it yeah and maybe it's
not even the same people it's just like
every week we're debating something else
right and it'd be called like debate
club yeah mock trial yeah we're on the
debate team ever uh was I I don't think
so
they would make you like to be weird
[ __ ] like debate team sounds like the
scariest thing of all time yeah it's
like you have to not only do you have to
be smart you have to be like there's so
many things you need to be smart
well-spoken like tough and sometimes you
have to debate a topic that you don't
even agree with like right if it's like
if it was like hypothetically like you
were talking about like pro-life first
pro-choice and you were taking aside it
like that's not even but you believe you
would have to just debate it cuz you're
mastering the art of debate right and
it's like when cher Horowitz is trying
to explain why you know her birthday
party it's like it was such a Hollis she
wishes fiftieth birthday yeah it does
not say RSVP on the Statue of Liberty no
totally debate club sounds like the
worst thing ever
totally oh the new also sounds like the
worst thing ever
the view is the debate club Oh totally
but next time times near knock corn up
in like when they get into it like it's
hilarious also what about Model UN I was
on model you back I know you I had the
greatest weekend of my life what did you
do there was the Model UN like well no
it was like a big thing in the city no
it was like in Connecticut Wow
I like had the most amazing time it was
really fun it was like um do you wait
which kind of charades
yeah but which country
baylin's like russia you know really
it's like it was just random what you
got that's so interesting I know I
really liked it and it was like there
was a Model UN team and me and all my
friends like a legit tried out as a joke
and we were we were arguing like
something about Iran and like I was in
there and like I we were literally doing
it just like to get on a team for
college and nobody made the team except
for me and then I was like alright I
guess I'll stay and then I like had the
best time you would make your little
placard out of like a piece of paper and
you would like write your country that
like prop it up to all the boys I've
loved before right that guy was a cutie
at the end there guys are Model UN yeah
yeah I turned off the movie the first
time before that like at the credit and
and then like I was in my sleep and I
was like wait this guy yeah and
throughout the movie I was like
something funny is gonna happen with him
like cuz we never heard from him yeah
someone I'm Michele furred if you're a
big 5 you have the best time I guess
there's like a big 5 like the best
countries to be interesting it's
definitely like America Russia UK
Germany France China China China oh yeah
I forgot about the East China and I
guess it to like depends what century
ranked wait and what's the topic like
that's the thing like if it was about
like industrialization and like my
country was Mongolia like I have nothing
to add do you know any mean it was tough
it was always unfair it was unbalanced
like Russia someone gets me America and
I someone gets to be like Cambodia this
is unfair
so it was like but I had a great time
okay next up US Open is criticized for
sexist double standard after ELISA
cornet was penalized for briefly taking
her shirt shirt off ELISA cornet was
penalized at the US Open for quickly
removing her shirt and putting it back
on a move from the open that critics are
calling sexist the chair umpire
Christian Rask hit French player cornet
who is ranked number 31 in the world
with the code violation effectively a
warning in the sport during her opening
round match against Johanna Larsson on
Tuesday cornet school dilation came
during a scorcher and Flushing Meadows
Queens on Tuesday it was so sweltering
at the US Open that the heat rule was in
effect permitting players to take
10-minute breaks to try to cool off and
drink water after their second sets
cornet was just returning
her ten-minute break when she appeared
to realize her shirt was on backwards
and so Cornett who was wearing a sports
bra underneath took it off to put it
back on correctly she was in disbelief
and can be heard saying violation for
what really in a video of the moment
when the umpire stated the violation
okay so me and my girl went to the US
Open yesterday and not as a player but
just as a human being it was so
unbearably warm and like me and Margo
we're in the Emirates suite and like
it's like this big air-conditioned suite
and then they have a like a box outside
that you can sit and like it was in the
shade and we had to go in and they were
handing out like cold towels like they
were like we were going in back inside
look to the air-conditioning for a diet
coke like every ten minutes like and all
I could think about was like the players
like Sloane Stephens out here like
working so hard in the Sun what was the
temperature I had you guys would like
maybe set over a like 90 but feels like
105 yeah the wind and there was nowhere
out right so it it feels higher so just
the fact that like home regardless of
gender you can take off your shirt for a
second it's just it's borderline
inhumane because it sound like they play
on cement courts but like you know it
gets even hotter because the cement
bounces the heat like not like a clay
court then like obviously Rafael Nadal
if he took his shirt off like like I'd
be like hey boys and everyone would be
fine with it so like obvious is just
classic you know non gender neutrality
which is just the world that we live in
and I can't even pretend to be surprised
about it anymore
but it's more it's less about the gender
thing and more about the inhumanity of
it all of the heat because just having
been there oh my god first of all the US
Open doesn't care about Jewish people
wait let me tell you why whose idea was
it to do like a cement court competition
in August Jackie I don't know but like
the fact that the uber drop-off was like
a mile away from the actual entrance to
the stadium it's like the US Open
doesn't hear about us yeah they don't
know no it's not for it's not for our
people put me and my girl woman got into
the Emirates sounds like it was so
swanky like the people who worked there
when you walk in we're wearing like the
flight attendant like cuting and they
gave us like hats and warm towels I mean
cold tell them we were just like
everything they were doing yes and they
gave the cutest ATS that I took three of
and brought home and I'm wearing the
Hamptons and the same shoe bar and we
were just
if they long do you guys say for two
hours was there did you say hi
no and the PR girl was like she wanted
me to him and I was like honestly I'm
gonna have to hit up Emirates for
something way cooler I'm not gonna like
waste my favor here you know yeah I
don't really like care about your some
Big Z was like cool to see he's like a
nice guy he was with his kids filiberty
yeah fellow celeb in the box and wait by
the way we ran into a lien from vetches
who is a friend of the toast and their
books coming out and I'm on the back I
wrote a quote we know when she was here
we talked about it oh yeah I said um she
was talking about the book and I was
like I heard you guys got some really
big names to write but there are
actually big names on it like Whitney
Cummings is on it and girls no job yeah
no I heard that too yeah so I already
pre I already prepped everyone I need to
pre-order it and honestly we all need to
pre-order it just so that my name is in
a bookstore or like that's the closest
I'll get it's deviling onion or New York
Times bestseller their first two were
near attempts at sellers like I'm gonna
be a nerd times the seller do you know I
didn't think that how it works but I
agree I use them yeah like put me on it
like I was shocked I was like oh they
must have gotten nobody it's like
Michelle wolf like Kelly Ripa
Kelly Britt but like true comics and me
I was just so nice and I was like so
honored because it's a book about like
careers working girls my job like I got
it and I'm like really excited about it
so our wait when does it come out I
don't know Mario can you can you imagine
Amazon are you ready for our fourth
story already sure in the boring news of
the day Campbell's is selling its fresh
food and international businesses
Campbell soup's bet on fresh food did
not pay off
the company announced Thursday that it
is selling Campbell fresh which includes
Bolthouse farms juices carrots and salad
dressings garden fresh dips and tortilla
chips and Campbell's own refrigerated
soups Campbell is also selling it's
international business which includes
Tim Tam cookie maker Arnott and Kelson
group the company tapped goldman sachs
and center be partners to help it with
the sale the decisions are a result of a
full operational review the company
began in May in the wake of poor sales
and reportedly rocky integration of
snack companies Snyder's Lance which
candle Campbell's completed in March
that's just so weird because all the
business needs to be report on is that
all these big food companies are moving
in the way of like health food right but
for Campbell's that didn't work and you
know that I currently live in a co-op
and I googled my owner and she's like
such a lovely lady and
turkeys like she like has this like big
apartment in New York I'm like doesn't
live in there like where does she
actually live and she is like very high
up a Campbell so I wonder how this is
affecting her job right now I wonder if
she was part of the fresh food industry
or like the old school stuff also I just
feel like when I think camels like I
definitely I definitely don't think
fresh like I think you know this would
be great for a bomb shelter and it can
last forever but it's also Pepperidge
Farm Campbell's is it yeah goldfish yes
so you have to think of it more of like
what else is in their portfolio off
limits said that the sales will allow
Campbell to focus on its core US
businesses including canon microwavable
soups v8 and pepperidge farm snacks they
should help bring down the company's
debt oh they're in debt everyone's in
debt yeah that's just to feel better as
someone in debt like everyone's in debt
you know everyone is in debt such a big
part of the company's in I'm sorry the
country's in debt yeah and like no one's
to care people I care but then they just
move on yeah like no I remember when I
was in my US history class with dr.
stone mr. stone got doctor and he was
talking all about the dead and then like
they weren't like worried about fixing I
remember raising my hand and being like
so like why aren't more people like
upset about the debt he's like it's just
like a part of like being a country like
you're in debt but like we're in debt to
China but it's like not fair that like
so as human beings aren't debt like we
got like our stuff taken away and like
the country is like setting the example
being in debt like they're not punished
no and they say and they're still taking
from us maybe some of us would be in
less debt if the country weren't in debt
like if the country got their [ __ ]
hands out of my pockets right and it's
like you're you're bankrupting outs with
taxes so that you could be in debt so
why do we have to look what's the point
just keep running up the debt if it
doesn't matter right all the things that
you're using our taxes for like just
lean back into China you know it's just
like it's it's so unfair and I'm sure
we're wrong about a lot of what we're
saying but like it just doesn't seem
correct no and it's like so we're we're
never paying off the debt right right so
like if you don't have to why do we okay
that's like you're not like you're a kid
and you're all out of have like dessert
before dinner but then you see like your
parents doing it right look what why
can't I you know it's true why can't you
have dessert before dinner it'll spoil
your dinner
that is not something
no it's like don't worry mom I'm not
spoiling my appetite when like three
nights ago I was in bed with bed and we
were going to sleeping we were talking
about our furniture and the dining room
table that I have in my apartment was
our dining room table like from growing
up it's literally like a family heirloom
and like I could never get rid of it I
don't really like the table base but
whatever and we were talking just about
I was like explaining to been like this
table and I was like we had assigned
seats like we had like literally like
every week it was like the same meals
Monday Jesus and I was just telling him
and then I'm like if you're my husband
like I don't even know like what you ate
for dinner as a kid do you know what I
mean oh yeah he done it was being so
weird but I was like okay so when you
got home
what did you do and he's like well my
mom can't just haven't dropped us from
school every day which in the city is
like unheard of I'm like oh my god
that's so nice and so she picked him up
and Maddie got out of school first took
Maddie who got picked up first and then
Ben we got picked up and then they would
go home and be okay so like did you like
have state dinner at the table like
every night he's again like well who
cooked who's been sad as a chef he's
like my dad worked every night so like
my mommy does dinner I'm like and did
you say like hey mom have a grilled
cheese or like she would make you and I
that was it there was like a set menu or
I was like you know and you can put in
requests you can order and Ben's like no
we could not put it over Crescent like
good like giving kids what they want
like that's not that's not good you know
yeah and so and then I'm like and select
what did you do after school like it I
just felt like there was so much about
Ben that I didn't know does that weird
yeah it makes sense when would you have
discussed it now I want to know those
things about that right cuz like we
would we grew up it was like dinner was
really important it was like we had
extracurriculars every single night like
we had that we didn't have one afternoon
off ever soccer we went straight from
school to either soccer practice art
class music school tennis tennis we were
even in a chess class remember yes Joel
his name was Joel five days a week he
was from Bermuda and we never heard from
him again we used to say that he got
lost in the Bermuda Triangle because
like we never heard saw him again it was
like we had full lives and then dinner
was like important like if you missed
dinner was like a big deal I'm like you
we never that was an option where would
you be like a sleepover you couldn't
like you had to come for dinner and then
go your sleepover and I feel like it's a
really good value cuz like now I like
love dinner I like look forward to it's
like a really special moment where like
families connect and that's where those
commercials where it needs to be like -
inner time gather around the table do
you remember those commercials from who
it was just like a commercial for dinner
do you remember that no I'm gonna get
that up okay I'm the hamburger helper no
maybe but it was like just like put your
phones down and be at the table like it
was like a commercial for just like
being at the table and it really is like
such a good I feel like thing to instill
in your kids I agree like we're gonna
have dinner like been chemist's dinner
with the kids but sometimes he'll have
to you like sometimes our dad had to
miss dinner extra that's true gotta put
food on the table literally literally
anyways I think Campbell's should really
focus on their cake up soups because
that is the future I can look at that's
a thing it's like it's kind of gross but
it's so smart it's so smart people do
you know that like you can make broth
out of a cake up like you how you would
put like an emerald coffee thing you put
like a candle singing and you get broth
it's genius but what is the difference
between that and a beverage I don't know
do you remember Campbell's chicken
messiahs they don't have like little
chunks of meat camless uh what was it
called handheld soup it was like sheep
and sheep and and had little starves
that was my joke good I think they still
sell bad they do but like Campbell's is
legit I agree Andy Warhol Progresso like
trying to be like Campbell's like please
I don't care who you pay for your
commercials you are never gonna be
Campbell's vegetables you know they got
a going in college I like will stocked
with Progresso a little bit so it's like
you get so many veggies in a soup it's
so easy to make so in a can I've been
literally I don't
I hate soup Ben loves why once I hate
about soup just like who loves soup
Ben Ben will happen Ben has a soup with
every meal yes I don't but it's such a
nice option sometimes you eat super dude
drink soup I eat soup yeah well it
depends if I'm doing a k-cup I have to
drink it because there's no particles
but usually the soup I get has chunks so
like vegetable soup soup is good when
you're using it it's like a dip for your
bread no soup is going to always know
yes French onion soup people who like
eat soup as a meal are like sick and
like need help features how do you feel
that's it's like French onion soup that
has like a [ __ ] croissant in it like
that isn't that as a meal
um I hate sue me to like well I hate
chicken soup so much it just reminds
iggle de Croy brat reminds me of being
sick I love difficulty parish it's like
a specialty soup that's different than
soup do you know what I mean yeah like
if I'm at
restaurant like where it spends on the
restaurant I'm probably not ordering the
soup because that is just the easiest
way to [ __ ] with people have been is
always getting soup at like the diner
yeah and he's like why is always not
liked Iser like why does it smell like
duty to do though because there's duty
in it yeah so we said if it's none of it
yeah it's not it's a snack for an
appetizer or an appetizer or a dip or a
small meal if you're like not that
hungry it's one nahi not - yeah yeah
yeah I don't think I've ever ordered
soup at a restaurant unless it was like
no I have French onion soup for sure
yeah but for the onion super special
that's all play okay are you ready for
our fifth and final story that's gonna
propel us into all of our TV recaps for
the night cuz that's all I've been
wanting to talk about anyway sure cuz
all I do is watch TV for the show and to
literally my homework yeah and I know I
know I literally I was like I have to go
home and I can't drink tonight because I
have to watch five hours of TV and
remember it all and have thoughts
totally I mean once we cut out bathroom
paradise for good
I watched pattern Paradise last night
just because like I see all this stuff
in the toaster oven I just want to know
oh did something finally happen
no but sort of anyways this is about
bachelor in paradise
leo continues to fight bachelor nation
on twitter quote i suffer from extreme
narcissism
okay so unraveling leo is a monster and
i never watch the episode of beca season
where he goes home so I don't know like
what he did and if he showed his true
colors all I know is the hair but all I
know was the hair all I know is the
softcore porn and he's battery and
battery oh yeah and then and Becca M
he's been like going toe-to-toe with
that guy I'm on Twitter and there's like
some sexual assault allegations against
him there are allegations that are the
Abeka MS DMS that's why they started
fighting my bed is at the center of it
well she was before now lis up now
America is has taken on leo
but before leo even got to paradise her
and Becca and more like him and Becca
and we're like fighting on Twitter
because girls were teaming back at em
about bad sexual experiences they had
with Leo I don't know if anything has
made it to the legal level yeah or
right like and how revalidating these
Becca mDM's she's posting them to her
stories and there's just like a lot of
them I'm dying
yeah anyways then less legit than I
thought I thought there was like a file
no I got the McKenzie file for Leo
existence no yeah Alex that exists for a
different bachelor contestant yeah oh
okay so then I got confused but like and
Becca M right Becca M is like obviously
such a third sponsor and I can't believe
she wasn't allowed to go to paradise
like you know tell me can you say why so
she's just like trying to keep herself
relevant so like uh I'm not one to doubt
a victim but I'm also not one to just
automatically say because some girl on
DNS says it that it's true for sure also
Leo hurt her friend Kendall so I think
that's why he's really going to bat for
her I have like so many thoughts on
Kendall anyways Leo dota vo is
definitely not in Paradise anymore after
attacking a man to Stanton and Tanner
told bear The Bachelorette alum turns
his attention to Jamie mile and join
Englert ten or toe bear that's his name
it made him French like Stephen Colbert
that's true it could also be tober he's
gay yes it's Tolbert the t is not it's
probably you know why I say it because
Jade's made a name is Roper yeah to get
it it's over repair toe bear but it's
like if she grew up in France it'd be
repaired so bad but she grew up in
Kansas and she's a Roberto Bert
but anyways I can play their two names
and I forgot that there's a T at the end
of told Tolbert Groberg forget it i
guess you got it as something that we
worked at first I never would have
figured out why I've made him a french
man totally
after the 31 year old Leo threw a drink
on grocery store Joe during the Tuesday
August 28th episode of bachelor in
paradise
bachelor nation was quick to call him
out on Twitter Amanda and Tanner were
among the first to throw shade which
prompted Leo to allegedly send Amanda a
D I'm calling her a piece of [ __ ] and
it's just money cuz you know man not
like she really is like what you see on
the show like everyone can actually
paradise everyone in bad star franchises
like so fake but like and that's what
you think of Amanda it's like no one is
that nice and no one like is that well
liked and then you meet her and you're
like oh my god you are like like you
weigh 90 pounds and you're like an angel
from God so like her being like told
she's a piece of [ __ ] by like this being
scary and bad with like George and John
later is like funny and sad it's so
funny because know her being called a
piece of [ __ ] by like an actual literal
piece of duty like it's funny and he's
also me and Jackie decided before the
show that we wanted like we want to
trigger Leo in this episode so he comes
for us next cuz I was the only response
is he says he's taking the doors down
and he told Tanner that he wanted to
settle any beef between them with a
physical fight quote last time I was in
therapy the doc told me I suffer from
Stream narcissism leo tweeted after
Tanner suggests so does it help quote I
tried to listen to what he had to say
but he had a reflective lamp that gave
me a perfectly good look at my jawline
needless to say I went I'm cured that's
actually funny yes when people get
creative with their insults know for
sure Nick was quick to interject into
the exchange tweeting breaking news
self-proclaimed Alfa suggest charity
boxing match with someone they have a
clear physical advantage over as a means
to inflate their own ego all the while
further demonstrating their deep
insecurities okay Nick all right Nick we
get it like it's not about you anymore
look you went to college right and now
like you're trying to like go viral on
Twitter
anyways that's when paradise leo went
home immediately after throwing a drink
at grocery store chose some security
guard literally jumped over Joe and
tackled me oh they must have had like
personnel ready for Leo because he's
clearly the biggest guy there people on
Twitter said it was a lot like who were
there that it was a lot worse than what
we saw on TV and like for the first time
ever like it wasn't dramatized as much
as it could have been like it was an
actual real fight well said that it was
like very straight and now well I guess
because like they don't want to be like
liable because rights aren't good for
the show no not at all
and like it's like it's not the type of
show yet but it's like they always
clearly out of control but what I don't
I mean a grocery store Joe is on Ellen
yeah Lea Michele yes what his thoughts
on Lea Michele filling in for Ellen
really quick um I don't know her
personality well enough to have an
opinion on it but it's random his house
random is how I'm heard like I'm her
number one fan me and Margaret the
presidents of her fan club and she like
loves Bravo which makes me love her and
she went on Bravo on watch Robins life
recently and like she's just like was
disappointing in the sense that she's
not like dynamic or like really like
like funny so I just think it's weird
for her name instead she's a great
actress and like literally the the
singer the Barbra Streisand of our
generation and she's not even given
nearly as much respect for that as she
deserves and I'm her number one fan I
just think it's a weird
section considering her watch what
happens live episode I totally agree
when I was like so ready for her to like
be here and like talk about Glee and
then also talk about Bravo like my two
loves but like what is grocery store Joe
gonna talk about and lastly editing was
or I'm sorry this was now Tuesday night
was so bad like they don't realize that
we
recognize what people are wearing so
Whitney be bianna is watching and she's
with Astrid Astrid
Ashley I love you and we love Kevin and
if you're not together right now in real
life like I'm done with you
I really think that they are they're
literally so perfect they had the cutest
date last night that he set up to watch
that's it it was to watch the sunset it
was sunset and chill and he made a fake
TV out of like sticks so they could
watch the sunset through it they're
literally so cute and I get off next
week actually I and Jared get engaged in
paradise and I can't forget it Kevin
Dean and Ashley so he's supposed to be
upset about it but like all he has to do
is look at Astrid your joy pure joy and
like pure coolness the two of them are
the voices of reason a are inherited
from a generation of bachelor that is
really no longer like alive on the tee
on television so like or his only her
only connection to the people in
Paradise is Kevin yeah but these are all
like new generation people and it's
clearly like Kevin's really happy with
Astrid all they talk about it's like how
happy they are and how surprised they're
because they're both like realistic
people I don't think they expected to
come to Paradise to actually find
someone so the both keep saying how
happy they are that the other is here so
of course they bring in Ashley to try
and like stir [ __ ] up between them but
they're so strong like please yeah
they're really cute I just realize that
Kevin won his season of The Bachelorette
oh dude so when he said like when I went
on The Bachelorette like I thought I was
getting married to her right he did go
home like first right and then that
didn't work out then he met Ashley and I
mean Astrid is it and I'm so happy but I
really miss baby on it like I her
absence and it's felt all that she is
like the Alexis of last season like
Alexis wasn't really like making any
matches but she was just like so funny
to have around and baby I'm I literally
saved tea and cold interrelationship
even though next week it goes down the
tubes and reality C wait hold on spoiler
alert spoiler yeah give everyone like 10
seconds how was it what is this I don't
know because people get mad and you know
what like I really have a laundry list
of things people are mad at me about so
like I just don't add spoilers to list
because I see whatever orange is a new
boston whaler alert 1 2 3 4 5
it's reality Steve tweeted that Colton
is probably gonna be the bachelor and
and then Mike Fleiss tweeted like
question marks as if it's not true but
there's so much lead-time between what
reality so you say saying and when
gonna announce the bachelor and so many
people are saying they don't want Colton
that I don't think it's actually gonna
happen but they'd love to give us what
we don't want ilanic file but I want
Colton I like Colton like he's only done
a few things that I don't totally agree
with but it's all in the name of like in
the bachelor world it's just like a
necessary level of like hatred hatred
and just you know you do what you gotta
do some that you a ssin and it's like
Colton clearly has played all of his
cards happened to this point to like one
continue to entertain Tia and to
continue to entertain the idea of being
The Bachelor and so that's what he did
what he had to do and I'm sending my
sister on the show I don't know like I
just I love him and then like I saw this
picture on his Instagram and he put up
like him getting paparazzi but like his
jacket over his shoulders like not even
his arms to the sleeves and it was very
feminine and I was just like maybe
you're not as cute as I thought do you
know they made you ever like see someone
in a new light and you're like well oh
not like it's it's Instagram that ruins
all of these men for me like all of
these guys with their short list photos
and their inspirational quotes and and
it's it's not doing anything for me so
it's like on the one hand Instagram like
fuels their career but on the other hand
it's like damaging the brand the brand
because like all of you will look like
major douchebag no and not even
douchebags like he looks like a girl
like sorry I really didn't like that
picture like it really pissed me off I'm
so sorry and like he was like just a
girl what do you think has his future
what beyond saying um yeah I want to say
that you could do better than called it
okay really over two things
hey you're the only one on the Colt
entry and I unfollowed him weeks ago I'm
done with him he makes no sense as the
bachelor like he just can't get his [ __ ]
together and like I'm just not down I
really want it to be Jason he's I would
go on for Jason because he's half Jewish
and I'm pretty sure it's the good half
which one's Jason Jason with the hair
with this look back hair no I'm sorry
he's like curly little hair like pay is
coming out from behind his ears the one
episode I watched ruined him for good
what if he had a glow up and like a
normal hair they love to give like the
bachelor bachelorette like the Botox
treatment like with a key for Chi
Lindsay a new pair of shorts and they
gave back I like new eyebrows but I
don't think there's anything they could
do to erase that image from my mind it's
like I had the image of Jason with his
curly little past and then in the image
of Colton like oh yeah cheffy Blake I
have I think he's the perfect choice
he's like like what they tried to do
with
sorry which works for me but like not
for the University Mac I don't know like
not Ben Higgins because I feel like
we've really run our course with him but
like someone like Ben Higgins someone
who's like Stillwell were spiked it
Wells wasn't dating Sarah Hyland
something like that okay Manzi you know
Ben's he has a girlfriend he seems
happiest he's ever been
Peter I miss Ben Z Peter Peter yeah like
you know Peter okay honestly just having
an in with Peter like whoever you know
here I'll change my mind whoever becomes
a bachelor
I hope follows me on Instagram okay
that's the one criteria or like loves
the toast BB said he cut his hair who
did it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
that he cut it it's just like I could
never forget that but that happened
right and I'm no longer interested in
watching someone who brings up that that
that negative feelings and I'll never
feel like he doesn't want to suck your
blood
wait exactly he literally looks like a
vampire and who's Blake Blake is the
second the runner-up who was so in love
with Becca and like literally was like
crying for days I'm just like I don't
know I just I can't care about this
stuff anymore like I'm really like I'm
out I understand well so Mitch I'm gonna
get your application just ready just in
case
honestly I would send you on for Jason
because like he's half Jewish in like
that could be a real match for you Yeah
right and like I would say anyone for
Colton just cuz like that's been my
dream since the would you like take a
semester off from college what would you
do you guys I don't know if it's your
senior year yeah okay I just I can't
handle I can't handle bachelor mansion I
can't do it no Margo it's like very like
emotionally no offense like big not so
stable I know anyway she's abandoned for
the show right but like also like I
don't I don't I don't think it's for you
like I think you're not good for it I it
was clap for me but like you would
actually be perfectly the show because
you are very emotional but then you
would have the toast to come on and tell
your side I mean for us it'd be great
right look pretty without makeup which
is just like a bare minimum necessity
like no one else has that platform it's
like they have to take to their Twitter
to say what really happens that's what
you probably I feel like people would be
destroying me because I have the number
one more you you target okay right then
my Bolivia like oh my god you're sisters
girl with no job like I want to be your
friend right but I think that my plan
would be I would go into the bachelor
mansion and I literally wouldn't speak
Mario your Jordan Rogers and Aaron
Rodgers like that's it except we talk if
we're friends yeah totally
so it's settled you're going okay and
then I just want to say the problem with
Bachelor Paradise it's evident in
Tuesday night's episode it's like
finally everyone's matching out
harmonious so they set so all the guys
who aren't in relationships get sent
home then they bring in three new girls
and there's no one for them to date
because everyone is just so happy single
does right and that's the problem they
need to be bringing in both genders at
the same time and then once you're an
established couple and you're boring and
that's great and you're actually happy
you should go to a honeymoon suite open
space for new people because it's like
it's like they don't really want people
to find love right it's like Eric and
Angela went on the dream bachelor date
where they just got to a hotel room and
got copious amounts of room service
dessert everything and then the next day
they bring in someone who's clearly is
there to meet Eric totally they and they
don't realize like if they still just
put like ten boys and ten girls and like
let them really frolic and didn't send
people home there would still be job
like they just think the drama has to be
so calculated and like literally they
have to be in charge of what happened
but it would still be amazing like
bachelor pad remember that I feel like
they were less involved you watch I um
I've seen a couple episodes they never
watch it but I remember it was like the
og paradise yeah and I think it was a
lot less like manipulated definitely so
it's good we're getting on a pointed
paradise when these people walk down the
stairs and it's like everyone's just
like seats taken
yeah it's really stupid and then House
is like looking less and less like cute
and more and more like a prison and
everyone is sweating like more than
usual and that area where they have all
the girls with their mirrors and the
makeup the fact that that's outside it's
like one of the most inhumane things of
all time I totally get like you have to
be natural like a shreds looks are
killing it because like her interview
looks it's like she's wearing no makeup
her skin is glowing her hair looks so
nice it must be nice any of course have
to like have an amazing body right but
you're also drinking all the time it's
just for so long I really thought her
and Whitney friends might we're like the
same person and now like Ashford has
just exceeded Brittany in every way in
every way and it's like and I just want
to like take a moment to panic dial
because I blame him for not giving us
more Astrid and he sent home Angela who
was the most beautiful person a angel of
a human being on night one she's the
most beautiful girl I've ever seen in my
life and Nick
I'll send her home at night when we
never got to know Angela right there's
so many like diamonds that we never got
to know but then there are so many
people that we got to know too well like
you know who did my dreams at like Jojo
like she like wasn't into Vinnie at all
but she kept him around cuz they were
like good friends and like I just like
like he was a great character do you
know any in the great chillin GT like
she kept Adam and Matt yeah long because
we're like yeah why because they never
gave him their time in the more like oh
my god Adams the dream man exactly
good call anyways I'm in New York oh my
god honestly like next Wednesday we're
gonna be a can oh my god what do we do
there's TV is there cable yeah they used
to stream or soccer games and stuff we
can stream on the Bravo app live oh my
god okay because that's gonna be like
next level they spend a lot of this
reunion talking about LuAnn who wasn't
there and like for the first couple
minutes it was fine but like it's almost
like they wanted to make it a three
parter cuz I could have lived without
like nothing last night really happened
to till the end with that Bethenny
versus Carole but like the stuff in the
beginning like I just can't believe that
the past Dorinda gets for that the
drinking thing because everyone is so
quick to jump on anyone who exudes any
size out like Sonja who by the way over
for like three reasons right I'm gonna
drink for three seasons because like
people didn't like her behavior my they
were able in her an alcoholic during
this behavior when she drinks his next
level unforgivable unforgivable like
Sonia used to only embarrass herself
right which is like other people and
ruins friendships Bethenny's colleagues
I don't even know my god worst offense
was gonna live or college I think that
was probably the worst if I was like a
seasoned Asus like because they live in
Haiti they're not going to college
that's what she said yeah it was
outrageous that was the most shocking
scene shocking and it's like he doesn't
even get enough play because the other
ladies weren't there right and they like
don't care and we didn't even know more
that happened that when she went back to
the warehouse Bethenny told us to get
unless weak steering in she apologized
to the wrong guy she was still blackout
she didn't even know so she went up to
one of the guys was like I'm sorry about
last night and that name is like that's
not who it was oh my god like that's how
drunk she was also like so underrated
that one and he said like what are you
doing to like better yourself and she
was like I go to therapy every two every
two weeks because I can't I know I can't
commit to once a week like what it's
like you think you're being like
accountable and self-aware but it's like
that's such [ __ ] and then she proves
how like unstable you are right it's
she thinks that that is like a good
answer and that she's talking to her mom
right and that like Andy like you making
a face at that like it's just why I love
him like cousin some and some were like
you do need to be impartial but like you
also need to call [ __ ] when you see
it and people are like up in arms with
Andy people who are pro Carol are like
up in arms with Andy but she's not like
him saying to Carol Bethenny admitted
she was like yes I did say that things
about you know like all those things she
wasn't lying that she said the list of
things she was just saying they weren't
like so terrible and Bethenny and then
Carol being like I mean I didn't say one
do I think about you like and then
trying to being like yeah you didn't you
didn't like backing her up like that is
just blatantly untrue
she said truly the meanest meanest
things about her especially in the blogs
because in the blogs and also knowing
what Bethenny was going through like
Bethenny was having so many visceral
reactions to things because she was
going through so much in her life and
Carole's really the only one there who
really knew the extent of it so like for
her to say that Bethenny is like so
toxic toxic when like she knows why
Bethenny's so excite all the time it's
like so she's better than anyone I
couldn't agree more
but then Angie chiming in and just being
like you both said bad things about each
other but she's like for a mediator a
very mediating things to say and just
the fact that that set her off is just
proof how unrealistic she is and how she
really is living in her own world and
then the stuff about the career was just
so epic oh my god that was the line that
we've been needing for so like first of
all Bethenny saying that she has no
career no husband no children like tough
you know definitely mean but they're not
flooded so you want to be nice to her
and they're not lies right no she's been
in Carroll saying that her and Bethenny
had the same career but was it you or
that that your resumes match up but
Bethenny when they bring your resume
into this era was the funniest thing
I've ever done that me wrong like
Carole's
resume is super impressive well it was
super like yeah yeah I mean now she
writes one column a month and throws a
party like that's not really like a
full-fledged full-time career okay and
what's not being said is that she's a
she's like a full time reality star now
which is fine yeah but it doesn't match
up to better women have that same career
- now that's jhinsley yeah it's like
Bethenny's on shark tank like right and
you can't even compare like please
Bethenny's a shark and I just hate that
everyone's throwing around this female
empowerment thing like really Bethenny
that's your brand of female empowerment
okay so let me get this straight Carole
we never empower you
even though
like you're mean and we don't like you
know Orleans you're a woman doesn't get
you automatic empowered work like I just
I think that's unfair and that's
Ramona's whole thing is like women
empowerment women empowerment like so
what we have to support you even like ok
explain this me Bethany has to support
you even though you say terrible things
about her you hate her talk behind her
back and called her tits fake literally
on my television but she she she still
has to support you just because you have
a [ __ ] like exploiting no and she has
to support your business even though it
doesn't exist yeah and you joined up a
formula or a lab look I really I feel
like I am a female empower like but I
don't necessarily empower people just
because they're women I think that's
almost a disempowering right and it
hinders whip-like it hinders progress
like I just think that's to me I
graduated on something that isn't worthy
of Carmen is like now this buzzword
where like if you don't do it you're not
you're bad where it's like I want to
empower women who are doing good things
you can also you can be a woman and be a
bad person like they're not the same I
totally agree and I couldn't like
Bethenny like it's Bethany's like her
shoulders haven't moved do you know what
I mean she's so unfazed by it like where
does it look at me look at us we're like
when you're when you feel strong she's
just like sitting back and she's saying
but like she's not invested in this
whatsoever
well when you think about what she's
gone through in her life and it's just
so crazy because it's like at this at
that moment at the reunion already the
worst it wasn't even the worst like
she's literally being been in court with
her psychopathic ex-husband like she she
can handle these women totally I just
didn't click the way she's really like
and she gets up next episode and she's
like booyah [ __ ] and that's epic but
she really is just so what come I agree
and like I'm not common this isn't even
about me I agree you know what I mean
also there was one really cute moment so
Tinsley and Scott's like they talked
about their relationship drama and also
it's like so weird how they date other
people what's going on in the comments
no people are I'm just trying to I don't
they're they're using uh pronouns about
she and I don't know who they're talking
about I think they're talking about
Carol they're talking about blind items
head aren't from seed and so it's not
they're saying they're applying to Adam
said about a girl in the closet I don't
that's definitely not true it's not a
blind Adam from crazy days and nights
it's not true so please stop citing them
thank you um when they show Tinsley's
package about her and Scott not getting
back together not being back together
and first of all I thought easily
handled herself really well
Scot think she's like when she said I
want Scot like I love him but when Andy
said about Andy is so smart sometimes he
said do you want Scott or do you want a
husband just a fair question told man I
thought Tim please answer like I mean I
think she should have said the truth
which is both I think her answer was so
genuine yeah I mean I just think like
last night's episode was really
should've been like part one at that
part one was better than part two which
it never is it's always like linear yeah
because the tensley stuff is so
uninteresting well they didn't spend
that much time and I put it I just want
the reason why I brought it up is
because also I feel like if Tinsley just
wanted a husband like she could go
better husband like she wouldn't be
dating some guy in Chicago like who is
like definitely not who she thought she
would be wine like I feel like if she
wanted just like a basic wine or husband
who likes a finance who works in finance
and like wants to be on TV she could
find that so I really think that she
loves Scott but if you watch Bethany's
face while they while they were watching
the package about Tinsley and talking
about tensley and Scott like she was so
happy for Tinsley and it's like this
whole fight with Carol is not about
Tinsley about Bethany being jealous of
Tinsley which is what somebody loves but
they love to say that because then it
makes Bethenny look immature Bethany
couldn't give less of a [ __ ] that Carol
hangs out with Bethany I'm not about
that I'm surprised if Bethany and
Tinsley wind up being friends and are
cordial because she was literally like
smiling every time there was like a good
moment for Tinsley she was like really
happy for her which I just thought was
really really it's a great point
right yes that's like it's not about the
Tinsley it's not about the toons live at
all but Bethany really like get has this
reputation of being like an ice queen
and there's so many people who like
Taylor Stryker was here just like I
remembered her she was such a [ __ ] and
she definitely does give off like that
Erika Jayne uninterested ice queen
better than everyone vibe cuz like she
is better than everyone but I think what
is missing and like Carol was like the
first person to really experience that
it said she really is just like warm
like loving good friend and it's like if
you take care of her she takes care of
you and that doesn't get showcased
enough but she's definitely a taker of
Carol to the Galapagos and Carol of
course she's America's house guest that
was the best phrase ever and I can't
believe that Carol didn't bring that up
in her notes because I actually I know
why she didn't because Bethany wasn't
lying I'm absolutely sure that Carol did
not pay her way I mean any of those
trips even though Ramona said I watch it
up inside after that episode that Carol
paid her way for for everything
including what would their days that
brought it up theirs
right if Carol had brought it up that he
would've been like are you for real and
Bethenny would have Bethenny's folder
pink folder I love when they bring
receipts it's so funny like they print
out screenshots also like this is gonna
be tough but Carol's excuses out this
summer that she wasn't like connecting
with Bethenny cuz she was in California
with her friend whose husband passed
away and then Bethenny was working on
crisis relief so like that made sense
but then like throughout the rest of the
months and even into the new year like
Carole kept like using that as it like
the reason why she couldn't be with
Bethenny's cuz her friend's husband
passed away like you can have more than
one friend you can have more than one
friend and like just be good like
totally it wasn't it wasn't it wasn't
enough for me oh yeah no it was
fraudulent and everyone just lies and
everyone it's like living in this world
Ramona's out of control I know she just
like his being it's like she's here I
know what she's doing she's saying she
stayed above the fray all season because
she like didn't like the feeling of
being like having pits all the time and
always having to defend and the last
reunion was she was like I saw myself
and I was terrible right she really
learned right she was always apologizing
she was the apologizer and she didn't to
be that person anymore so she stayed
above it this season she missed the
drama no one was talking about her
this reunion she's going she's saying
the meanest things possible suggest this
to them about her and everyone's
ignoring her and she's taking the side
of the majority because I think she
thinks that's what the audience will
take and she's just like this hope this
show is her life wait oh my gosh we
watched the first episode of Real
Housewives of New York last night and
Ramona was working in fashion
she resold like overstock to items to
different department stores like she had
like a job and she and then she did that
true faith that she did rejuvenation and
I Ramona like she does not have a career
actually she doesn't have a career so
this show really is like her whole life
and I think that she knows whatever the
audience feels is like the way that the
network will like absorb so she really
thinks that like being on the side of
the majority means that she'll be in the
right and she won't be like ostracized
like Carole and then get fired like so I
think that Ramona's taking the side of
what she thinks the audience thinks is
right not what she actually thinks is
right
right and then as being the most
outrageous just so she can be relevant
right because she like she and joy I
think she realized this season that she
enjoys the drama more than she enjoys
being a where the silicon Serena learned
that she loved not being in the drama
100% because you can still be relevant
and not be in the drama but you just
have to be like interesting and cool and
people have to like you funny but I
don't think Ramona's is that risk of
being fired like ever she's also the
only one on the show who's been there
since season one all the way yeah
Bethany was there from season one but
not all the way now my only win was
friend of house wife for a while for one
season
Ramona has been the head of New York for
a very long time and she doesn't want to
lose a position and she got that
position by being scrappy and below the
belt she's going back to it that's true
that's true but like it counts for Lily
and also I just might want to say
Giovanni this is what's so frustrating
and like it's it's not like this is all
hearsay like we have footage like we
know when someone's like I didn't say
that and then there's a clip of them
saying it like their temple so she said
this is what dureena said she said I was
no I was like Giovanni Giovanni and like
we have the clip it's like why are you
lying to us like it's it's just not true
takes false also I thought what they
said about LuAnn and how everything
happened like the relapse happened was
so interesting how she reached a level
of Fame after the arrest and the shows
and it's like I didn't even realize like
she was always so famous but I didn't
even realize how much more we were all
talking about her and how like larger
than life that she had be I mean by the
way she's but it makes sense cuz we just
said that like literally last week we
were like she reached out like I'm
status yeah and it's like that's true
and that's why like that's a lot for a
person especially after 10 years of
hustling and now you're landing demo
Grand Marshal of a San Francisco Gay
Pride he demoted to friend of housewife
then into icon status is no easy feat no
and it's hard to keep your head on the
ground yeah that was really interesting
I thought for the most part when they
were talking about her sobriety everyone
was like pretty respectful except like
[ __ ] know that Chris Burch is party so
what points guy was here and he was at
that party and had with a beacon no no
at Chris Burch oh and he was like they
had this like a world class prodigy
pianist playing for the party it was
like the soiree and LuAnn showed up what
he said in like walked on stage like
right in front of the like the world
class pianist and I got a drink like he
was like it was still bad so but Ramona
and like I think that did make Paige
tick but like Ramona just saying things
we were at the Beacon and she to be
carried out like
[ __ ] cuz like she's Luann's obviously
in like a low state and then to like
she'd highlight things that never be to
the press luckily it's just so low yeah
that's a Ramona but it also helps us
understand that like this wasn't like oh
she just had a drinkin a she's back in
rehab
yeah this was like a months-long thing
and I felt like I got a better picture
of how everything happened yeah the way
that I did and I also just love them
talking about like Luann's Fame and like
really breaking down the fourth wallet
like the show how the show like reduces
elements that affect their lives and in
turn that we see on the show and then
Dorinda was like saying it and almost
like an attack kind of way she was
Bethenny you knew she was drinking a
Bethenny was like yeah I did and I know
what the proper protocol is it's like
when you're when someone you know is
like relapse saying like the second they
do are you supposed to like intervene or
are you supposed to let them hit rock
bottom like what the right well so LuAnn
went to rehab because of the arrest but
not be like we were talking about this
on the show meet and we've said that we
don't know much on the subject but like
we know is she an alcoholic like him she
never have a drink again did she go to
rehab needed a break and now she can
like drink in moderation so maybe she
did start with one drink and she was
fine no that spiraled so but when she
went to rehab the first time I
definitely thought it was just like a
court-ordered thing and like she just
likes to drink and one time took it too
far but now with this whole spiral I
definitely feel like she's a much more
like in the program and and needs to be
sober agreed and can't have a little bit
but maybe when she was drinking like she
wasn't Bethenny didn't need to be like
oh we need to send her back to rehab
yeah cuz and she didn't go to rehab this
time for like two weeks I don't know
they're gonna start filming soon and I
hope they I hope they bring up the
cameras they're supposed to start
filming already
really yes because I had heard from like
a very good source that maybe like a
week or two ago they were supposed to
start filming we're filming earlier but
Dennis Dennis so I don't know what
happened and they dedicated the episode
to Dennis and he was mentioned one last
night it's just like I thought that was
weird cuz it was like a like everyone
was fighting like you'd like to like
dedicating something like [ __ ] do you
know what I mean yeah it was like such
an abrupt transition but it was it was a
nice gesture
it's so sad like it's so I watch Bethany
on
I'm like I'm sad for her and then I
remember like when she's where she's at
right now and like it's it's okay she
doesn't even know in the Radian like
what's coming yeah but she looked me and
Margo couldn't tell me about it like
gorgeous the best she's ever looked so
nice top five housewife look for like
about any reunion and Sonja I'm gonna go
top five house by the look yes she just
looks like clean sober Sonya is just the
best song but she's not even sober no I
mean uh yeah I guess she's not sober
because she drinks like up like
leisurely socially but she's just not
sure he as much as she's doing honestly
I think her French break in friendship
with Ramona was really good for her I
don't think she could have gotten to
this place of like clear lucid Sonya if
she was still like Ramona sleeping in
the bed together having people unpacked
for them drinking margaritas I feel that
Ramona is like toxic and a lot of ways I
know you're not watching Dallas so I'll
just make one quick point and I'm gonna
I have I'm having a staycation I'll have
done everything with obviously like met
but this episode is good because I feel
like Cameron being on the show is very
odd but now it kind of makes sense
because she is like a level of wealth
that none of the other ladies are like
Stephanie I thought was the richest
Cameron is richer what about Deandra no
are you sure yeah I don't know about
that because oh by the way so they you
learn them a lot more about the company
the company has this one product that
makes up like 90% of their deandra's
company yeah and it's like this pill
that like I never heard of it's coming
nature of something so they're
definitely wealthy but they're not like
probably plain wealthy no but I don't
think that company is where deandra's
wealth comes from she's like oil oh
right yeah that's just like a fun hobby
for them that's true well just just what
you get from the show but I take what I
get and they actually did a lot of
research on Stephanie's family be calm
in Locker it's so interesting it's like
and that's like legit like they're rich
every Locker that's an equinox SoulCycle
and then they're ones no stadiums like
every team are made by Travis holmen's
company like anytime you think of a
locker room like for sports teams arenas
so like I like its Holmen like [ __ ]
equinox yes no it's epic and it's just
such an interesting way to make money
like not like stockbroker right and I
love that me too until other ladies are
definitely like of a certain wealth like
I think that Brandi Carrie are like the
same like just because
well wise but it's just Cameron is so
uninteresting and like so dumb and like
her storyline is just so bad and it
never made sense why they brought her
back because everyone hates her but now
you know why she is true like Dallas
well is she better this season
no she sucks and this episode really
made me [ __ ] hate her even more right
I'm gonna catch up this but I'm sorry I
have to talk about it's not a big
spoiler okay you know Brandi adopted a
baby yes and I knew I don't mind the
spoilers it's like sometimes you say
something and then I automatically like
when I watch it I it's like your your
leg yeah sorry and it's like I wonder if
I watch it on my own if he would have
the same opinion you definitely have
this guy so that's why I'm saying it so
it was really cute Stephanie threw her
the this surprise party and nobody knew
really except for Stephanie so all these
people are coming in like the room is
blue and they're like what the hell is
going on and Cameron figured it out
she's like Brandy's pregnant she like
figured it out and in the Blue Room or
look at the party okay and Stephanie
really wants to keep it a surprise she's
like no like I have a surrogate like I'm
having another baby and Cameron was like
so happy for I was like really cute and
it was like a lie um but like 10 seconds
later no no maybe 30 minutes later step
it up Brandi came down holding the baby
and I was like really cute and
everyone's really happy and people were
like shocked like really nobody knew and
it was like a hysterical thing for it
was like so them but now that this
episode they're going to Beaver Creek
which is where Cameron's family's cabin
is and it's sick like Hallmark vibes to
the next level they took her plane and
it's obvious that like all the women are
super wealthy but they're not at like
plane level because they were excited
about it where I was like in Beverly
Hills like okay good we're fine you know
yeah yeah it's just everyone was like
excited about it so it was really funny
and they get to the house and it's just
like epic and gorgeous and they're
wasted like they're just not Brandi is
wasted cuz Brandi's like I literally
haven't slept in three months like this
two-day trip is everything and she's
like she puts all of her eggs in this
trip and it's like so exciting for her
to her in 70 share a room and Cameron
obviously just out of nowhere goes I
can't believe that you kept her baby a
secret like like I was so upset and like
left out and like Brandi I mean I don't
know what it's like to have a mom to
have a child but like I'm sure anyone
saying even something remotely negative
like affects you and you're drunk Brandi
didn't even and Sheila got up and
started hysterically crying got into bed
and went to sleep like she was so upset
and Stephanie's just defending her and
she's like we can't just like sit around
and like bash someone's baby I'm Cameron
thought she said you're bashing
someone's baby what she did it and
Cameron goes oh she said she doesn't
have any in her house anymore and
Stephanie's like trying to say I didn't
say that by the way even if she did say
that um she's entitled like but she
didn't say it and it's like and I think
I'm they showed a preview for next week
I'm 90% sure Stephanie goes home
Stephanie gets into a car by herself and
then all the other ladies go skiing and
she's not there because Cameron is out
of control like Cameron is very like
she's not smart she's not interesting
but she's very talented and you wanna
know what her talent is she has this
innate ability to make everything even
someone else adopting a baby about
herself
it was the most atrocious thing and like
I know you could just think of it as
this moment but that moment so perfectly
encapsulates what is wrong with Cameron
like it's like this amazing time in
Brittany's life I her and Brent Brian
went through this like hard time and
like this baby has brought them together
and like it's just amazing she's so
happy and like he's different and
Brandy's trying this whole day to like
be fun with caman and like they played a
little prank on her and like she didn't
get mad about it like they're really
moving in the right direction she tries
to kiss her on the lips like it's really
funny and Cameron is just like thirsty
for a storyline and she's gonna make her
bones off of Brittany's new baby and no
one is having it even Carrie Carrie
Carrie it's like badger badger badger
cuz she's like when you fight with
someone Cameron like you badger down
about this one thing so anytime she
would bring it up the baby thing Carrie
is like badger badger badger and no one
is on camera inside except like DM
there's like kind of like just like I
don't know I'm like annoyed Deandra
deandra's always it stays out of the
fray and like his friends she's a very
much a voice of reason I have to watch
now has Leanne you haven't mentioned her
once so she's not really like in the
thick of it yet she's like still
pretending to do like meditation and
yoga and then I think a lot of the girls
make fun of her for it and that's her
downfall I'm pretty sure that's what
happens and she's like trying to teach
him automatic meditate her and I think
her concern is like getting back with
Brandi because I think they really did
have a real friendship and I liked it I
agree and I'm here
like LeeAnn Stephanie Brandi against
Cameron Cameron has to go I'm sorry like
I'm really annoyed with her last night
really upset me like t to even like make
one thing negative about like such a
positive thing in someone's life it's
like such a nasty thing to do but then
like to make it about you like first of
all they're not even that close that's
the thing and that's what's being said
first of all you and Brandi [ __ ] hate
each other you are only civil so what
the biggest secret in her life where
nobody knows should you expect to you
didn't though
you're nobody to Brandi you're not even
your coworker
you're a co-worker and not even a
favored one at that I can't stand
Cameron and like last year like I didn't
like her just for like superficial
things like the stupid dogs but like now
she did something evil and I know people
think I'm probably overreacting but it's
so indicative of what a bad person she
is like I'm so angry about it I'm so
team Brandi the end all so to say like
to someone that you don't want them in
your house just because they disagree
with you in any other housewives trip
everyone goes to everyone's house LeAnn
took out a knife on Murray in brandy and
Stephanie's house they never kicked her
out of the Hat no totally like she was
just like wielding her house and her
plane over everyone like she bought
everyone monogrammed what's the point of
having a house in a plane if you're just
gonna be mean about it
totally she bought everyone like pajamas
to wear on the plane and D'Andra was
like I don't make that ass and they look
terrible I mean they were striped
pajamas so she didn't wear them and
Cameron like took personal offense to it
she said you know how long it took me to
get the monogram or like she's using all
this stuff as like a weapon where it's
like the quality of Mercy is not
strained
hey don't you guys think for people who
are just gonna throw it back in their
faces I'd rather fly commercial takes
all the fun out of it I'd rather go on
spring break to Daytona yeah and Carey
was like stirring the pot a lot last
night like I liked it
you like Harry now um well when she's
anti Cameron I'm on Team Carey but like
Carrie brought Cameron into our lives
and she continues to defend her except
for last night and I think that's
unforgivable but right now I'm cold
Carrie cool I like I like them all
actually every Dallas housewife that
we've met I love so much I'm right now
I'm behind everyone except for Cameron
I'm like i'ma starting to almost like
turn on Deandra yeah because she's
there's a whole thing with her and
Brandi where she's just right up line
okay I'm gonna watch it all this weekend
I'm so excited for this long holiday
weekend let me show you I'm going to the
Hamptons at the points guys so ever get
the tea every room in his house is like
named after like he's so just like he's
so true
brand because he put me in a group chat
with like a bunch people saying in his
house is that Claudia and been like
you'll get there before me so make sure
to take London I would sitting that's
our city yeah and he's like John will
you say Tokyo like it's like so him like
you know are the rooms themed I don't
know haven't been there so I'll let you
know okay and get the tea night he is
the best tea
he really does okay I'm so excited we
will be back here on Wednesday we'll be
releasing one more patreon episode
because the month ends tomorrow and it's
actually gonna be really fun episodes
Maiden's doesn't know that we're doing
this yet but he and I are gonna record
an episode of this where I'm gonna get
his thoughts on the news of the week
could I like tried to do that with Ben
once and like when it comes like when
Ben was co-hosting here like he just has
the weirdest opinions I'm like things
though like oh we're we are connoisseurs
of like housewives like I think it'll be
interesting to it like for you to see
what Zach thinks because it's really
weird because like we're the same like
you guys game thoughts but like to
introduce a new opinion it's like always
kind of jarring it really is like when
Ben was giving his opinion on Deer
toasters I was like are you just saying
that because it's wrong right you know
and sometimes I do think Ben says things
just to be contrarian cuz that's very
him but he really does have like
different opinions and I'm sure Zach
it's gonna be like very it's gonna be a
little shocking
shucky anyway so if you're looking for a
toast episode tomorrow you can find a
patron calm slash morning toast we will
see you next Wednesday for tuning in
what a fun big a week this was her
little boys and just like getting back
you know I was gone a lot and you then
you were gone and now we have like
pretty much a full week and merch oh
right I'm camp toast this next week's
Thursday it is not too late to get your
ticket no there's like five more days
until you can buy a ticket
Lincoln bio at our Instagram password is
all caps premium thank you guys again
for just like making this week epic
selling out the merch we love that we
love you
we're gonna continue to deliver premium
content we are I would say I'm a caterer
I cater to the needs of the toasters and
I feel like we pretty much listen to
sermons but civil servants except not
for the like we're private service when
we forgot their toasters whatever
thank you guys so much for watching the
morning toasts make sure you follow the
morning shows on Facebook and YouTube
because we live stream everyday 10:30
a.m. Eastern Time Monday to Friday not
everyday just Monday through Friday and
then we're also available in the podcast
app for those commuters so make sure you
subscribe to us there and that's all she
wrote have an amazing holiday weekend
and be laborious and make sure
to wear white after Labor Day or else
you will be toasty roasty that's why I
wore all white today so I didn't want to
be like Josie
you